weapon rides and slap your cheeks it's
almost weekend and Vlad is here with a I
am your neighbor you are good to see you
all here a few stories we think you'll
be talking about today live alarming
health news about longtime NBA
commissioner David Stern the league
announced the 77 year old needed
emergency surgery after suffering a
brain hemorrhage stern reportedly
collapsed at a Manhattan restaurant
yesterday and was rushed to a hospital
at this point we do not know his
condition Stern was a lease commissioner
from 1984 until retiring in 2014 this is
sent shockwaves wish him we wish him
well but ad during those years hit the
average player salary jumped from 250
thousand dollars to more than five
million dollar right I mean that's what
he did for that lead they added seven
teams they expanded dramatically
everybody got richer the game guy and
much more property yeah magic he did
Magic Johnson I said this I joined
cookie and praying for my good friend
who helped save my life the former NBA
commissioner David Stern that's how the
league feels right now wishing him well